Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Je viens d'avoir 24 ans.
Jeune diplômée prête à apprendre
une multitude de choses
et j’ai dans mon assiette
une carotte râpée.
Je regarde l’emballage
et là, je découvre que cette carotte
râpée vient d’Italie,
qu’elle est passée par une centrale
d’achat à Rungis
avant de retourner
dans une usine en Bretagne.
Là, elle va être transformée par
une ouvrière ou un ouvrier mal payé,
pas très bien valorisé dans son travail,
qui va avoir pour mission
de rajouter des colorants
pour que la carotte reste
bien orange, bien belle.
Des produits chimiques pour uniformiser
le goût, pour le standardiser,
pour plaire au plus grand nombre.
Et je me dis :
«Mais qu’est-ce qu’on mange ? »
(Rit)
Du coup, pour comprendre, pour savoir,
je suis partie sur le terrain.
Je suis allée à la rencontre de celles
et ceux qui font qu’on mange,
mais qu’on mange vraiment.
Et là, j’ai découvert l’Auvergne,
mon Auvergne,
celle dans laquelle je suis née.
Le territoire que je pensais connaître
par-delà les montagnes.
J'ai découvert des femmes,
des hommes passionnés.
J’ai découvert
des problématiques écologiques.
des problématiques économiques.
J'ai découvert des valeurs.
J’ai découvert l’acte même
de manger, ce qu’il implique.
Je sens que je vais vous perdre.
Alors je ne vais pas trop en dire plus.
Mais derrière la carotte que
vous allez manger ce soir,
il y a Christophe.
Il vient d’avoir 40 ans,
il a monté sa ferme en polyculture,
à 40 kilomètres de là.
Derrière le chou que vous allez manger,
il y a Alain, qui vient de reprendre
l’exploitation de son père
et qui, chaque matin, découvre
les problématiques de la terre.
En fait, je peux vous raconter
une histoire derrière chaque chose
que vous allez manger ce soir
parce que j’en ai fait mon métier.
Je suis une épicière
au service de mes producteurs.
Donc, je ne vais pas vous dire
grand-chose de plus,
si ce n’est : « Ce soir, mangez,
savourez et savourez pleinement. »
Tout ce que vous allez manger est à 95%,
de la boisson,
jusqu’à cette fameuse carotte,
issu d’une agriculture locale et paysanne
dans un périmètre de 40 kilomètres.
Et je tiens particulièrement
à remercier Max,
Sarah, qui a pris la relève
sur le terrain,
Amandine et Anna qui vous ont râpé
avec amour toutes ces carottes
que vous allez manger.
Et voilà, vous savez ce qu’il y a
derrière la carotte de ce soir.
Alors je vous souhaite
un très bon appétit.
(Applaudissements)